sally morgan is trying to join the
meeting we can't get in
is she in the waiting room
chair we're live now if you'd like to
start the meeting thank you okay thank
you very much indeed
well good morning and welcome to the
oversight and scrutiny committee
all participants are now taking part
remotely and we are live streaming to
you on youtube
there will now be a roll call for
confirmation that members of the 20 are
present
trish can i ask you to carry out the
roll call please
yeah um council
austin
councillor d cox president
councillor evans president councillor
hayes
president councillor herc gordon hook
councillor morgan
councillor nuttall prison
councillor parker khan president
council pedereck present
counselor um councillor swain
present and yourself chair
thank you i'm present and we have
apologies from councillor tomb
thanks very much i can everybody please
make sure their microphones are muted
and when you're not speaking to avoid
any background noises
sally morgan is still trying to join the
meeting
well i'm sure she'll come in when she's
uh thank you
okay can you please keep any point short
and do not interrupt when somebody is
speaking
if you wish to comment please raise your
electronic hand and wait to be called
when it comes to a vote if we are to raw
call the democratic services officer
we'll read out the members names
but members please say if they are
voting for against or abstaining
alternatively the vote will be taken by
show of hands
we will look to have a break if
necessary at a convenient time some 90
minutes into the meeting
if members lose internet connection the
meeting will be paused for a few minutes
to allow the members to rejoin
so if you move on to the agenda trish a
gender item one apologies
the only one counselor to
and leader of the council as well
councillor connect thank you chair
thank you very much item two uh the
minutes of the
last meeting on the ninth of february
have been attached to the uh
agenda can i have any questions about
the uh
the agenda about the minutes of the
meetings
there's no questions can i have a
proposal that we accept those minutes
please
i have linda pedreck proposing have a
second after that thank you councillor
nuttall
uh can we throw a show of hands please
show acceptance of those uh minutes
i think that's unanimous are there any
votes against those minutes
any abstentions from those limits
i see nobody indicating either an
abstention or
voting again so unanimous vote for those
minutes
item three on the gender declaration of
interest i have no degree
or are there any declarations of
interest that people wish to make
nobody's showing a wish to declare any
trust
public questions there are two public
questions and though
answers have been provided and sent to
the person who
raised the question but i think in view
of the fact that the two questions
relate to the important decisions
to be made by the council about the
investment in the
center of newton now but i think we
wiser i write
i read out the answers to those
questions so they're probably in the
available in the public domain
so the first question what provision of
meaningful activities for the youth and
disadvantaged groups does the current
project plans
actually offer the answer provided by
the council
it is too early in the process to be
able to comment on specific activities
and it is necessary to consider the
proposal as a whole
the future high streets fund award will
enable the council to develop more
detailed plans for the market quarter
which includes the alexandria cinema the
market hall
along with the market square how the
space is managed and used will be formed
part of the considerations for the plans
as they are being developed
in more detail as part of the bid
to the future high street fund the
market quarter proposals included
a combining and transforming the market
and food hall alexander
cinema and market square to include a
new eating quarter
a state of the art cinema a remodel
entertainment an advanced venue
and a high quality market space
the attracting investment in these
important heritage buildings to make
the market quarter a more attractive
destination
changes to attract greater football and
increase the time visitors spend in the
area
extending into the evening and so
supporting the wider town centre economy
and opening up access and making
improvements to the market square to
allow events to take place
including greening the area and
providing seating
the second question was have any
entertainment professionals
for example touring groups musical acts
comedians entertainment agents
have been approached to canvass their
thoughts and opinions on whether they
would be willing to use the proposed
space
the answer from the council is the
submitted business case for the future
high street fund was produced with input
and support from consultants and
architects
with experience of delivering similar
projects across the country
when we developed the projects in more
detail we will engage with a range of
future uses of space
to design a high quality offer as its
role changes from being a separate
cinema and market wall
to become a more flexible entertainment
and entertain and
events venue and high quality market
space
an overview and scrutiny group has also
been looking at the provision of
cultural facilities in newton abbott
their remit looks at the current
provision excluding the alexander
theatre
but has included and received
receive seeking input from diverse
groups interested in the arts
including the current users of the
alexander theater
the group work is ongoing and will
report on how newt nabot can develop the
basic requirements for an improved
cultural quarter within the town
so that is the uh those are the
questions two questions asked and the
answers provided
so moving on
item five council questions i have no
questions posed to me
sorry sorry sorry sorry before you move
your council i
apologize uh profusely for jumping in
but i can't get my hand to raise
i'll work on that um the the question
you just answered
was sent in anonymously because there's
i thought i have no details i have no
details of the actual name of the person
that's
sent it to her counselor book but the i
know
having checked that the answer has been
returned to whoever sent it
thank you for that i just wondered
whether it was now
the process that we don't announce who's
given the
put in the question because formally we
always have
i think that there is nothing on the
answer provided by the council that
tells me who sent the question in
okay thank you chair if i may we
chair yes of course yeah if i may um
we don't have um individual names
named in the zoom meeting or on the form
um due to data protection thank you
okay thank you for that right moving on
to the executive
forward plan in the executive meeting
took place earlier this month there were
24 items included in the
executive forward plan
as we now have two ons groups we're
asking
that the executive identifier within
each of their items
which of these items on their plan
should allocate to each or both
of the ons groups that
information will be passed back to the
executive asking them to do that
equally there are projects on the
executive forward plan
which have an expiry date of 2019
so um we'll be asking that the executive
forward plan is
is brought up to date where it can be so
we can have an effective
document to work from are there any
questions about the executive forward
plan
i see no hands raised or questions being
asked
okay so can we move on please our work
program therefore i think questions
about the work program
are there any items on our work program
that so you want information
on anything that i've had no
notification of any new items to add to
our real work plan
nobody okay
right in that case can i move on to uh
first of all
the executive member buying your
presentation so the first one is
is cancer taylor here is cancer taylor
booked it
yes thank you so council taylor thank
you chair
can i hand the meeting over to you sir
thank you uh
uh thank you very much mr chairman
thank you uh for inviting me to the
overview and scrutiny to committee
today to make this executive member
presentation on
planning as members will i'm sure
appreciate today's planning presentation
is once again set against a backdrop
of considerable uncertainty for the
building and new homes industry due to
covid19
for much of the last 12 months a
government lockdown dispensation
has allowed the wheels of our housing
industry and its supply chains to keep
turning
sales of homes have also been kept
moving thanks to
a shot in the arm for from the
chancellor in the shape of a stamp duty
holiday
an incentive which he extended for a
further short period in his budget last
week
but the social and economic aftershocks
of dealing with the pandemic
have yet to be fully registered with
potential consequences for where we live
how we work the housing we need and what
we can afford
where we do have more certainty however
is on the question of the government's
calculation for housing numbers across
the country
gone is the proposed algorithm which
could have more than
double doubled the housing requirement
here in team bridge to 130
1 532 houses per year
instead there is a return to the
standard formula
with a rebased calculation of underlying
housing need
and an affordability multiplier taking
the total to just under 760 houses per
year
requirement whether this multiplier
will make housing here in team bridge
any more affordable
is not really for us to speculate but
what i can say
is that i'm sure there will be plenty of
people wanting to take up a new
95 mortgage to buy a home here
and many others also who will be looking
to us and the recently announced team
bridge 100 local authority housing
scheme
for assistance in keeping a roof over
their heads
in the meantime and the expectation and
in the expectation that the 700 the
expectation
is that the 760 number will not change
at any time
soon it is now this number is now going
forward as the baseline requirement for
our 20-year local plan
update under part 2 the allocation of
sites
following the extended consultation on
part one policies
last summer but before we take a closer
look at the local plan update
we should first turn to housing supply
matters
as shown on our slide seven
as this shows two very important metrics
on housing provision performance
the forward-looking five-year supply
measure and the retrospective three-year
housing delivery test
failure to meet either of these targets
by any significant margin
could result in a developer winning an
appeal against the planning refusal
through the presumption in favor of
sustainable development
at any greenfield site in team bridge
in the tinbridge local planning
authority area that is
members will i'm sure be aware of recent
newspaper articles and email
notifications
reporting an over delivery of housing
generally in devon
for many local planning authorities that
is the case
however in 2020 timbridge dipped below
100 for the first time to 98
with the very real possibility that
unless the net downturn in numbers we
have experiences
experienced reverses remarkably this
year
the presumption rule would soon apply
here
furthermore if housing completions
continue to lag behind the housing
delivery test target
a 20 buffer would be added to the local
plan requirement
in place of the standard 5 buffer an
increase from 760 homes to 2280
additional homes in the local plan
given this scenario it is good to note
in slide 8
that the draft local plan update is on
track for public consultation in june
when proposed new sites for housing can
be assessed in a strategic
and a local context alongside our low
carbon strategy to help combat climate
change
a settlement limit and hierarchy review
will also form part of this consultation
process
sharing an understanding of how various
housing sites
may be linked and phased to allow for
necessary infrastructure to be in place
prior to occupation
while options for employment development
be that starter units in a small town or
village
location or strategic warehousing at a
major trunk road junction
can also be considered alongside other
masters such as gypsy and traveller
sites
the draft plan site
options found in slight slide 9
show that the call for sites which has
been quite successful
has resulted in some 370 sites being
submitted or identified for assessment
for inclusion in the local plan
while many of these will have been
submitted primarily for housing
following an initial officer assessment
some will have been considered as more
suitable
in whole in part or in combination for
employment
or for green infrastructure such as
public open space
or sustainable travel corridors
where initial assessments have raised
concerns about deliverability
for instance for minerals topography
flooding
ecology or landscape sites have been set
aside for review
under a healer process a housing and
economic land availability assessment
by a specialist panel this panel process
which comprised of four meetings
were completed last week with sites now
coming before the local plan working
group for discussion
a sustainability appraisal stage will
then inform the remaining strategic
options prior to the public consultation
in june
brownfield urban capacity sites are also
being assessed and are expected to make
an important contribution to the local
plan new housing total
either through upper floor conversions
of the shops in the high street
and extensions or through site
redevelopment
stories of the demise of the high street
are overdone i believe
there will always be a place for the
butcher the baker
and the hairdresser in our town centres
especially in those revitalized by
investment and
in migration as exeter has proved
and i look forward to this
transformation as i'm sure we all
do turning from spatial planning to
development management
slide 10 gives some detail of the major
development applications or projects
that have been assessed by our planning
team in the last six months
including the approval of applications
for over 600 new houses on allocated
sites
approval for a new through school at
southwest exeter in exminister
and significantly the refusal of a major
scheme which failed to provide an
adequate proportion of affordable homes
these six months have been a challenging
time for planning workload capacity
management
not only because of the high number of
minor household applications that we
continue to receive
pointing perhaps to residents preparing
to improve rather than move in the near
future
and the new disciplines surrounding
covid that officers face
but also because of the high number of
leaving returning and newly recruited
staff
one officer has thankfully now returned
from maternity
with three more returning in the next
few months must be something in the
water
four new members are now in place all
having settled in really well
with one more arriving this week and
with some temporary support for interim
cover
slide 11 shows that our development
management score on the timetable
on the timely determine
our start again shows that our
development management score on the
timely determination
of major minor and other applications
is above target on all counts although
it is acknowledged that there is a
backlog of
older applications including those where
an extension has been in greed
which the t the dm team are keen to
reduce
priorities going forward are to support
the delivery and to reduce determination
and officer time
through taking a tougher line with new
applications that do not meet
requirements
slides 12 and 13 bring us up to date on
the newton abbott garden community and
related delivery
officer work with evidence gathering
over the last 12 months
including connecting to nature and green
infrastructure
transport strategy including bus routes
and improved crosstown
cycle paths and crossings urban
development site assessments
also for consideration in the local plan
and in developing a vision for the town
in
2050 to take forward for public
engagement
a stakeholder workshop is being
scheduled for later this month
while news of capacity funding is
anticipated soon
which would aid further work on garden
communities including
master planning the redevelopment
slide 14 gives us the latest picture on
the district heating network proposition
which is hoped
will heat in excess of 2 000 homes in
team ridge at medford
powered by the viridor operated energy
recovery facility at marsh barton
while some resistance remains to be
overcome
the saving on emissions provide a
compelling argument in favor of the
scheme
as does the backing of team bridge
through a sustainable loan
towards this project the do nothing
option
is not an option slide 15 brings us to
the last of the presentation
the planning team's priorities for 2122
which aside from the local plan
consultation covers
link road construction starts in both
dawlish and newton abbott
at house houston barton the provision of
the southwest
exeter countryside park the sangs the
strategic alternative natural
green space provided at x minster
uh by a sill to maintain development
close to
the x estuary and a pledge rather than a
priority to deliver
good decisions in the interests of the
whole community well
who could argue with that finally to
advice chairman in the interest of
keeping the presentation short as
requested i have not dwelt on last
year's successes
or headlines which you'll find in slides
four
and five and i hope you will take those
as read
while i can advise that the two council
strategy programs for which i am the ph
namely great places to live and work and
moving up a gear
which are detailed in slide three
uh are both on track and if there is
further information that members would
like
on these i'll do my best to respond
in closing chairman i would like to take
the opportunity to thank the outgoing
head
of devon building control andrew
carpenter
who is hanging up his site visit high
vis for a well-earned retirement
after over 40 years in the business at
the end of this month
i'm sure all those who know andrew want
to wish him well
his experienced successor nigel hunt
joins us on april the 6th
mr chairman members thank you
thank you very much indeed sir and thank
you for keeping the
presentation to the point and uh within
the timelines we ask you to do so
are there any questions uh for the ph
from the members
i can't say i've got a number of
questions um
in terms of the impact of the current uh
delivery of homes can you tell me how
many homes we've delivered have been
delivered
uh last year and this year please uh the
reason i asked that question is
obviously
the council benefits from the new homes
bonus and the
question therefore is what is the impact
of the shortfall of housing delivery
on the new homes bonus and what is the
impact therefore
on the seal payments that the
district and the towns and parishes
would have received
i don't actually have those those
numbers to to hand
i'm afraid chairman but i can i can get
those those to you or the
or the ph4 housing perhaps uh would
would like to
would like to do that i'd be grateful if
you could arrange for
uh information deeply provided that'd be
fantastic
um can you also
tell us the
delivery of the 100 homes that
the council is engaged on the first
seven homes that are being built
are significantly higher in cost than
the
price of equivalent homes it could have
been bought can you tell us what
uh value for money calculations take
place when these decisions are being
made
again chair i mean that's really a
matter for the executive member for
for housing uh i know that uh the
um the costs have been um
shown at uh that committees
um uh in the in the run-up to the uh
the application going forward and uh
that uh
they they the the costs were showed two
members at that point
under under part two conditions thank
you in that case i'll
ask the question directly of the ph for
housing
and lastly a further question again i'm
not sure if this is for yourself or the
ph for housing
the council has just received a cash sum
from the government to provide a hundred
homes with air source heat pumps can you
say how that or where the decision will
be made is where the
money will be spent and how those
properties are being selected
um i can't say where but i can say they
will be
that the money will be spent and there's
certainly um
money that would be very gratefully
received for
for uh helping with uh with climate
change in teambridge
thank you for that are there any other
further questions any member wishes to
post
i say nobody ain't katie thank you very
much
just as i said that three hands popped
up on my screen so
first of all counselor hook
thank you chair you must have a slow
pop-up but we won't go there
councillor patrick has been uh anyway
moving on moving on
um gary you you will know that i was
particularly disappointed that um the
guest
situation collapsed around us uh
a year or so ago well six nine months
ago and i think that was an appalling
and dreadful
situation brought on not by team bridge
of course but by
essentially uh east durban and mid devon
um
and i've attended and you mentioned the
the local planned working group which is
a
an essential and very uh positive
committee and i i think the work that's
going on there is
you know probably very very good and um
and it will go out to public
consultation which which is absolutely
right
um can you speculate or
do say if that's an unfair question i
don't mind you saying that's an unfair
question but
can you speculate as to whether there
have been any gains whatsoever from
coming out of guest
and what we have lost because i'm aware
of certain losses
but i can't see any gains based on the
local planned working group
meetings that i've attended we seem to
be covering exactly the same
um ground as we were covering under the
arrangements with guest and all we've
done is lost the benefits of
the association with with guest and uh
the the advice and the
money that will come with it so i'm
still
disappointed that we're that that system
collapsed
what gains have there been well
uh thank you for the question uh gordon
i'm i i am it is
it is regrettable the in the the way
that the guest
did come to an end however i think now
with the benefit of
some hindsight i think we can see that
it was probably
the time for the for the parting of the
ways
um we we we're on we are on different uh
local plan
timetables to to exeter to mid devon
and to east devon and i think uh that's
reflected now on
um on that particular direction that
they are taking i
saw a recent press release from from
east devon uh which
which showed that they are still at the
uh
a very early stage with with their local
their local plan
and i think that might have held us back
you know in uh
in the course of us trying to um
get our get our local plan through so i
think
we're we're we're actually lighter of
foot but we're
but we we still carry
two uh the two through to consultation
uh the the the good work that was done
by
by the guest team um and
it'll be useful to to have those members
who were seconded
to two guests back in back here in team
bridge
for for the heavy lifting now that we're
it that we really are in the teeth of
the local plan
and getting this in getting the the
sites forward so
so i think i think uh guest was right
for its time
we've moved on the time is now it's all
about our local plan now
i remain to be convinced but i'll listen
to what you have to say gary as always
thanks very much uh councillor parker
khan please
thank you and thank you councillor
taylor for your presentation
um something that wasn't mentioned on on
your as part of your presentation but
comes across
certainly my my inbox as a
district council and perhaps for many
other people is the issue of enforcement
um where there are planning breaches and
i know that there have been some
significant
difficulties due to coronavirus and the
restrictions on site visits and things
like that
um are we at full capacity with the
enforcement
team i think there was some talk about
an additional enforcement officer
and do we know when the business may
resume as normal
um as regards site visit and enforcement
cases
are considered i think we all want to
know when
when we can get back to normal uh
council of pakistan
um as for the the enforcement team we
are
actually still one down and
i'm sure an officer will pop up and
correct me if i'm wrong but we have
been using the the the bud the budgeted
funding that we have to support uh that
the enforcement team in in other ways uh
from
uh from other using other other members
of the depart
of the memphis department to to help
fill in some of the gaps
uh it's a it's a it's a very it's a
difficult and sometimes thankless task
and enforcement i've seen i've seen some
some
things come across my desk and i know
that phil our chairman has
two um but at the end of the day it's uh
much of it goes on um
understandably uh uh in privacy
and only really comes comes to uh comes
to light uh when when enforcement
uh uh moves perhaps to a
more legal footing although that before
that we're told that
that the matter has been cleared up
through a planning application
so so yes my apologies to uh to members
and to members of the public who who may
feel frustrated by the process
there are guidelines on on the website
which are worth having a look at if you
want details of
our policies and uh and other matters so
so it's well worth looking at those they
may help but
in the meantime um i'll do my best to
uh to to help the the team
get to get to where it needs to be with
these things thank you and i will say
the officers are always very very
professional with what they do so
by no means saying that they're not it's
just i know the capacity is a bit of an
issue for them at the moment
thank you sarah that's very kind of it
thank you and i have
counsellor linda frederick please thank
you
chair just a couple of questions you
mentioned a through school at
exeter does that mean primary
through to high school
yes it does thank you and what does
hierarchy review mean because i didn't
understand that so um
it's it so it's a way of
actually just stacking up what what it
what are the best options what are the
best
sites so you may need you may need to
unlock
one site to get to another site so in
terms of which is developed first that's
that's uh that's sort of his
self-explanatory i guess um but
but but also it's it's how far out
things are from
from local services or from transport
nodes
so you would want to from for the sake
of sustainability
the developing uh sites which are you
know closest to
to all those facilities before you look
further out
of a town or village center
um or yeah you you
you look in there in the round to see
whether there
are um infrastructure
require infrastructure requirements or
or or um or things that would be
good to help unlock uh not just housing
but other
but other important facilities um and
um and to develop a better plan
through through such through such a
review
thank you thank you are there any
further questions from members of the
committee
are there any members of the executive
would like to raise a question
i'm seeing no no indications of anybody
wishing to speak
in that case uh council taylor can i
thank you again a very irritating very
detailed response to the your portfolio
and i
appreciate you doing that thank you very
much indeed thank you
okay move on therefore to uh item nine
the executive
member councillor mcgregor sports
recreation and culture
good morning chair good morning
okay i'm what i'd like to do is unlike
uh
councillor uh gary taylor where there is
a considerable amount of work going on
uh my my report will be necessarily
brief
um just bear with me two seconds
um my notes have disappeared so
i'm trying to figure out how i get with
those back okay i'll just carry on then
um in terms of the um sport
leisure uh sorry sport recreation and
culture um
portfolio the the impact of covid has
been extremely significant
leisure centers and have been closed
activities on hold and that includes all
our leisure centers and and swimming
pools
playing pitches moogoo tennis etc health
and well-being activities conservation
tasks and
events in parks and resorts have all
effectively been closed
there's been no income coming in through
any of those sources
and we now have dates for reopening and
restarting of the activities
the schools are back um as of as of
yesterday
so that has meant that two of the sites
have had a small amount of staff because
schools use those sites
for um swimming and and leisure
facilities so so we've got a small
amount of staff that have come back in
to to do that
from the 29th of march outdoor sports
both adult and junior
will will be allowed so tennis courts
golf
pitches you know people will be able to
play on the pitches
and as of the 12th of april people will
be able to use uh
the gyms go swimming uh there'll be
junior
activities family courts and
family swims so that'll all be be
allowed but it will be on the basis of
restricted access
um as as we had last year
and that is the expectation although we
don't actually have the clear guidelines
outlined for each date yet um from the
17th of may
group exercise adult indoor sport will
be allowed
and again we're not entirely sure how
that's going to look because the
guidelines
haven't been issued yet and we are
awaiting those but preparation work is
being done on the basis of
what we expect from from last year and
possibly
you know adjusted changes to to increase
increased capacity
from the 21st of june all things being
equal
the uh all restrictions should be lifted
and therefore
uh sauna and steam changing ribs settle
will all be open
and we expect to a a return to normal
however normal could be normal last year
where there was a restricted capacity
we don't know what that restricted
capacity will look like we don't know
whether there'll still be
some restrictions in place for social
distancing etc
or for for cleansing etc um
and booking so yeah we are we are trying
to prepare for that at the moment
officers are very busy doing that but it
is mostly around preparation work for
those dates that i've just covered
on the next screen my next slide please
uh the t10 program out and about an
active has
effectively the data is on hold uh
you'll note from the last two reports
that came to ons
uh and and other meetings that we
are in what's called amber but
effectively that's because it's closed
we can't make improvements because we
can't do any activities
um there have been some activities going
on behind the scenes with or behind this
this program freeze um including
the um in step program which was
effectively a 510 people joining into
a let's step together process um an
exercise program
which had 15 000 sorry 15
plus million steps registered to it over
the period of the
of the actual program running which is
equivalent of a trip from london to
cape town and a little bit of the way
back so from our perspective that's a
very successful participative
uh program that's carried on um
there are um open space um
programs going on we have under 18s 30
to 60 years and over 60s
but it is very very minimal and mostly
managed um
on a very very strict covid
basis we need to review the targets for
next year in light of the covert impacts
and some of the funding that we receive
is based on
certain targets so we will need to to
have some time to
uh negotiate funding going forward for
those
um and and possibly assess the different
set of targets and how those targets are
measured
the leisure center refurbishments are on
hold but the decarbonization works
um announced this week by the newsletter
are to take place between march and
september it's a very strict
requirement the funding is provided on
the basis that
the works commence before the end of
this month and
are completed by the end of september
it will mean that the lido remains
closed for the entirety of the
season unfortunately but it does
represent a massive improvement both in
terms of
the equipment um that we'll be putting
in there
and reducing the operating costs as well
as the carbon footprint from that
particular site
and also the same applies to newton now
but leisure center and broad meadow
in terms of the um the grant the grant
funding comes from the national public
sector
decarbonization scheme um
and it reduces our carbon footprint
across those three sites
by an expected 280 tons of carbon
dioxide
that's the equivalent to 100 houses
across the district
running their heating on full blast for
a year so that's a significant amount of
uh
work towards reducing our carbon
footprint as
a portfolio and adding to the council's
overall target which i'm sure will be
covered in more detail
by councillor hook in her delivery on
the
climate change portfolio
next slide please um
budgets the furlough and income
compensation schemes
have uh saved a lot of money across the
the um
the set the the um the delivery of the
leisure centers
and i think it's really important that
we we recognize that
that has actually saved a huge amount of
money for
the council it's covered a lot of
expenses uh having the leisure centers
closed has reduced our operating costs
um but the uncertainty means that we
really are
hopefully going to be lobbying for uh
extension to the scheme
while the uncertainty remains in place
we're not entirely sure how the scheme
looks
going forward from from april but we
should have a better idea as that
information is is fed down to us
green spaces ranges we've we've had
income losses from the pitches events
beaches etc
but we have seen increased usage by the
public across parks
um you know walking etc and
some of the work that has gone on um
within the parks has been done because
you know we are we are seeing quite a
significant increase in in
public use cemeteries there's been no
difference
um to budget or no significant
difference to budget projections
and thankfully um there has been no
increased demand
despite the covert crisis thank you
next slide please
business as usual operationally in parks
and the nature reserves and resorts
the decoy play park improvement works
are out to tender
uh that's um that's hopefully going to
be resolved very quickly
uh the bakers park refurbishment nearing
completion
and the mafford sangs phase one is also
nearing completion um
in terms of decoy park the um
decking by the lake has been replaced
it's looking really smart and tidy
and once the um once the play park has
refurbished this year in accordance with
uh
approved expenditure from from from last
year
uh we'll see a much improved facility
for
children um to use and parents to bring
their children down to um
in terms of the sangs we we have that
going and the phase one's completed
we are hoping that that will obviously
attract more people to go out and out
and about an active
and then we will start to feed that into
our t10 projections once they start to
open up and and he's going forward next
slide please
um in terms of leisure centers the team
bridge together campaign i i've
covered that that's the step campaign on
demand and live streaming programs have
been offered to
to residents across the district um i
know the staff have been in contact
directly with one or two users to help
them and support them through the
process
um staff training and development
activities have taken place
throughout the the follow period as well
so to ensure our staff are still
um you know
being kept warm and there's nothing
worse than being out and furloughed and
not having any contact so we are
ensuring that our staff are kept warm
and and um
you know welcomed into the into the team
and and the development activities will
help improve their uh
ability to do their job going forward as
well property maintenance has been
carried out for instance the decking at
decoy park by the lake
and various elements across the across
the portfolio
we've got our chartered institute
partnerships approval
my notes do say that we have got two
elements to that one is partner working
and the other is trainer partner working
and that's chartered institute approved
it's a big feather and a cap to get that
membership and administration and
communications has been improved by
by the app and we are
going to probably have uh one or two
queries in terms of membership fees that
have covered during the closure period
but we'll be able to carry those going
going forward and carbon reduction
improvement bid
projects they they have been won and
they are being implemented
as we speak so all of that included um
things are looking quite quite rosy in
terms of the actual leisure centers
themselves
i will say that unfortunately dornish
didn't win out on the the carbon
reduction improvement
because it already has quite a high
level of
reduced carbon output because it's got a
biomass
heating system rather than a gas a
natural gas boiler
redeployed staff which is the first item
which i didn't cover initially
leisure center staff were offered to all
of the other departments that required
extra staff because of the extra work
that they were doing
um i don't have the numbers that were
actually deployed by i suspect it was
quite low because
having developed their their systems and
processes
over the um previous two lockdowns it
actually looks like they were very very
efficiently carrying out
the the details in in the last lockdown
um
last slide please
uh challenges going forward getting
leisure facilities back up and running
as safely as we can um it's all being
lifted in stages which is quite nice
uh the financial recovery will be the
key i think um
going forward and refurbishment of
centers
um that's not including the
decarbonization process but the
interesting aspect of the
decarbonization process is
that the business case for refurbishment
included renewal of some of the
equipment
that will be covered in that process so
we still will need to do a business case
going forward
but we won't be able to do that until we
see what income level
and attendance level and usage level we
have after the covid crisis
i suspect some people will be nervous
about coming back into crowded
environments
um so that may impact it in the short
term but we know for instance
there's quite a lot of interest in
getting the swimming pools back up and
running
as quickly as possible um to you know to
get
encourage both clubs and individuals
health and well-being
which brings the health and well-being
of residents you know we have a
fantastic set of facilities
a fantastic set of officers and and
contractors managing that process for us
and they've kept it open and tidy and a
usable space that people want to use
um you know having been down to
michael's field recently
um you know the the usage is much
greater than i
i thought it would be at this stage and
people are starting to now already get
out and about
uh we're going to be looking at funding
activities in parks to get that kick
started back up
and also we need to to look at our
sustainability of costs within within
the portfolio as a part of the council
so you know from that perspective the
decarbonization reduces operating costs
for us hopefully across the
the patch uh which then adds to the the
savings going forward
into the the coming years um which has
has been covered
in the exec reports by council keeling
next slide please
and that brings me to the end any
questions please
thank you councilman are there any could
you take your uh
displays down thank you are there any
counselors with questions for council
mcgregor
i see no hands raised one question uh
councilmember gaga
pleased to see that the works at baker's
field are
progressing and will be uh completed
hopefully soon i've had a comment from
the people running the
air ambulance air ambulance
of concern that uh they were given plans
for the
pavilion and location for the
uh their investment of putting lights
for the emergency landing of helicopters
which showed the or put the lights on
the wrong side of the pavilion because
the pavilion had been rotated around
have you any
feedback on that or do you know what
happened there i haven't had
any feedback or input from from devon
air ambulance at all on
in respect of the the lighting facility
but if that has been done i would
suspect that would have been corrected
um as being impossible for a helicopter
to land behind a pavilion because
it's a slope um and the flat area is
actually
further away um on the football pitches
away from the trees
so it was it wasn't floodlighting could
i ask you to just follow up with it the
devon air ambulance just make sure that
the
facility complies with or will meet
their uh minimum requirements
more than happy and we'll drop a
confirmation though into the members of
the committee as well
that's very good thank you very much
nate for that are there any other
questions gordon you had your hand
raised
mute you're on unicorn
thanks cheer sorry thank you um
first of all thanks to to andrew for the
the uh
very positive presentation and report
really really good and lots of
interesting things there not least of
course the decarbonisation program which
is just
fantastic news for the council um
and that that will be a big big plus in
terms of our
uh outgoings and and carbon footprint
really really good that's that's
excellent news i'm afraid i was a bit
distracted during the presentation
however because i was trying to just
clarify
one or two points that i thought um were
erroneously made during the housing
presentation and i
i got clarification and um we probably
can't go back to that but but
just to to um say that i may have list
therefore
the answer to the question i'm going to
put to you and in that case i apologize
for giving
i think i think we all agree across the
council that we need to become
more income conscious we need to raise
our
our income not necessarily by raising
costs or price charges but by
increasing participation levels and if
you get 100 coming
to have a swim as opposed to 50 you're
going to get 50 more incomes and so on
um i'm aware that some of our facilities
i'm thinking probably of pitches
for team games and so on were to an
extent
under used previously and clearly
they've been not been used
during the the lockdown are we
undertaking or
do we undertake promotional work to try
and increase the usage of our
pitches um do we make approaches
directly to
cricket teams or or football leagues or
what it might be to to encourage and
make aware our facilities because i know
for instance the ones in your own um
your own ward in michael's field
are probably not used as much as they
might be and yet the facilities there
are really good i don't understand why
um they aren't being used more and i'm
obviously
i'm sure you are hopeful that with the
increased
uh availability baker's part with the
new pavilion and so on those will be
even more used are we promoting in other
words and how
i did have this very very conversation
actually with um
with the lead officer um there
there was an article on dev bbc devon
radio um
recently and it was a discussion with
david james the former england
goalkeeper um
those who follow football probably know
who he is don't probably wonder who he
is
he was a very he he was a very positive
um
supporter of of not just football but
all sports
particularly from village leagues so you
know from my perspective you know
he he made some absolutely brilliant
points we we do have a case where
we need to support we need to use more
um
interestingly we there's an organization
called saint southwest that we're using
during the summer last year during the
easing of the lockdown
michaelsfield every single day and they
had between 120
and 150 um children
uh training on those pictures at
michaelsfield which was absolutely
fantastic to see um it meant
actually we had to put a little bit of
maintenance work into the car park
because the usage
got so high and i don't think the car
park surface had had that much usage for
quite some time
so we are we are looking at usage and we
are looking at how we're going to
maximize that
um i think from my perspective my
biggest concern
is that you know where there is usage
currently the covert crisis has
impacted small clubs either with
loss of funding or loss of interest
and that's actually more more worrying
in some respects because a lot of
interest in in two or three small
villages
you lose a league you know you lose a
league so we will we will have to um sit
down with devon county fa at some point
and talk about what they're doing to
encourage uh football grassroots
football locally
village leagues etc and and find out the
best way to support that going
going forward um and i think that also
applies to rugby
it applies to cricket believe it or not
probably applies to
the much much discussed croquet pitch at
ford park as well
thank you uh can i move on are you happy
yeah yeah thank you uh
counselor not all please uh thank you
chair this is not a question it's just a
very brief comment
um last week my fellow ken valley
councillors uh
swain and foden and i had a presentation
from the team
implementer overseeing the the
development of the matford sangs
um outside which will be part of the
southwest exeter development
it's absolutely fantastic it's a very
imaginative
um project and i think it's going to be
a very significant addition
to the green spaces in the district and
i i exalt people
to come have a look at it in the summer
once it's open to the public it's going
to be quite spectacular
thank you thank you very much
i haven't i have no other
committee members wishing to ask a
question don't have any executive
members wishing to ask a question
i've got no
i just have your hands still raised
cancer not all
no i have no further questions in that
case uh
can i thank you very much indeed um
councillor mcgregor thank you for a
presentation thanks for keeping it
within the uh time limits we asked you
to that's very easy
just just before i go chad i just want
to say yesterday was international
women's day
and um i think it's it's it it behooves
us all to
um thank all the women in our lives for
for the effort
and um excellence they they bring to our
lives
and i think uh i think i'd just like to
say that thank you
i don't think anybody on the committee
would disagree with you
thank you can we move on then to um
item 10 which is the report of the
employment sites task and finish group
which
um was a group that i was involved with
so if you don't mind i'll give you an
update or give synopsis
i take it everybody has a copy of that
report and has had the opportunity to
read it
right the principles behind this
investigation
was to establish if we could the
reasons behind why team bridge for the
last 10
years or so has not delivered
the sort of employment growth from new
sites that we've projected and
uh wish to see so it's really to
understand
the background reasons why those sites
weren't coming forward
whilst over the last i think it's eight
years we've seen
growth in employment of between six and
eight thousand uh jobs none of those are
associated with
major site redevelopments so to
investigate the
group was created to talk with the
appropriate people
and establish the opinions of um
the professionals in the in the field to
come forward with
things they could identify that we ought
to be looking at and the things that
weren't working or things that weren't
working within
team bridge the group invited
representatives from other councils to
come and talk to us
representatives of agents of people who
own or bring forward development
our own counsellors and we had a series
of
presentations which i found personally
to be
very very helpful and very informative
and it was
consistent in terms of the messages that
they came forward with and those
observations are contained within the
report and summarized within the report
but fundamentally the report identified
i think it's 11
areas of concern or areas where we
believe that
the council should be looking to address
why
the work isn't coming for why the jobs
aren't coming forward
the overriding thing though is that the
perception was that the council lacks
an overall strategic plan for the
delivery
of employment and that what we actually
need within the council
is that sort of plan to develop
creating enjoy creating high paid
employment is extremely important
an important task for us as councillors
and i think uh one of our primary
recommendations the executive from this
report
is the executive commission the
production of
a detailed plan to create employment
so having said that can i go around the
members here who are part of that group
council not all
would you like to say anything about the
uh about the report or observations of
the report
not much to add to what you said chair i
think the the overarching thing for me
was that as you said that the lack of a
strategy
a strategic approach um which we heard
from
i think almost all the people we spoke
to so i think that was the overarching
thing that i'd like to emphasize thank
you
is there anybody else would like to make
a comment about the report
are there any questions there for um
about the report or information that
you'd uh like to have
or more background details on gordon i
see your hand raised
uh council sarah parker yeah thank you
so sorry thank you
thank you chair um i have a few points
um
if we started going through the report
and i think the report was very valuable
and i think i think the
members concerned who took time to
produce it are to be you know thanked
and applauded for
what's here so what i go on to say isn't
meant to be um
negative it's it's just to add to what's
there uh in
um in two two one start off with
i mean that is the crux of it isn't it
and that's i think what
generated your interest in the interest
of the the members that we just not
delivering employment sites and yet
in in our local plan we have a lot of
sites designated for
employment but they're not coming
forward and as it says later on
that's probably because the landowners
are waiting
for that to fail so they can convert to
housing and
and uh that's singularly unfortunate
um it's very disappointing therefore
that these sites
haven't come forward and i'm surprised
in a sense that
the people you've consulted haven't
included devon county council who have
quite a large responsibility or
department working on
similar to our own employment generating
and i
thought that was a a place to to start
an
interview ditto it may have been useful
to
have got say southwest employers or
let engage because th these are agencies
which
i've thought had a an insight into
the potential of our area and and may
have come forward with
positive suggestions for uh advancing
our case
um so i think there's there's a
piece of work still to be done on on um
essentially working border blind and
across
across borders with other agencies that
at the moment
well i i didn't see that in in the
report um
it does say you you held zoom meetings
with east devon district council and
and so on and jll and tony noon i'm
afraid i don't know who they are but
that's
that's my problem not yours um but i
i would thought that devon county and
and the left and so on would have been
agencies that have been worth exploring
um also
members will know that and i'm sure we
all are very very keen to increase our
income
generate entrepreneurial activity um
that it's alluded to in the report
um but not really developed at all i'm
whipping down through the um
report here in the conclusions um
it talks about seven three talks about a
team which needs an investment plan that
focus on the delivery of employment
sites yes it does
but it also needs i think as a cancer we
need to look at ways in which
we can generate income for the council
we
we just need a complete change of
mindset in my opinion that we've got to
become
as a council entrepreneurial not
exploiting
but but um capitalizing wherever we can
on money making fundraising
business-like activities
i mean i've made various suggestions in
the past and i would like to think that
maybe this committee or or a new
equivalent
would actually take forward the ideas of
that we can all bring forward every
council member of
where and how the council
can become more entrepreneurial can
become more
business-like uh you will know i
advocated at crematorium
uh that we could build and run i think
that where there are new developments
um for instance um on the edge of newt
now but
we perhaps as a council could
build and run the local shop that's
going in there
why not other councils are doing
not dissimilar types of activity and if
we are
concerned about improving employment on
the one hand but generating
income for ourselves i think that could
be an extension
of the work of this committee thank you
thank you can i just come back and
answer a couple of the points you make
there firstly
the role of the committee was look
employment sites and the delivery of
employment sites
we totally endorse and agree with you
about the need for a much broader
perspective which would pick up the
things you're looking at but we're
suggesting here that that should be
referred back to the executive for the
executive to decide
the actions it needs to take the other
point i would make is that you talk
about
devon and the left i agree with you when
we spoke with
east devon district council who've had
extensive workings both with
the lep and devon county council
they make the points that you actually
refer to
or make the point of how the district
council works
uh to deliver their employment sites and
it was pointed out forcibly by uh east
devon
um how those things should be done and
the responsibility rests back with the
district councils and how it works
to overcome the issues that we were
highlighting to them
so we felt that we had the input from
the
people who'd worked with the two people
you're talking about even though
we couldn't get those uh people to come
and talk with us jones langla sell the
people you don't know the biggest
um commercial property agent if i could
call that
in europe and they have an office down
here in exeter focusing on the southwest
and we spoke with our south west
uh officer who looks who actually lives
in team which
works within team bridge and represents
a lot of businesses looking to invest
down here
and noon roberts is a local commercial
property agent
who again represents a lot of landowners
down here specifically within team
bridge
and therefore his views and look jones
uh
langlacel gave us a spectrum of
representation which covered the
smallest
the largest landowners and business
opportunities that
are coming down here it was from jones
langlacel who've got this
requirement on their books highlighting
1.5 million square feet of
industrial employment space that the
district needs
they also highlighted the fact that the
current age
about industrial properties
predominantly within team bridge
are now over 25 years old and therefore
a less
fit for today's use that's required
and they also highlighted the the point
that
most opportunities currently are coming
from
warehousing manufacturing and
distribution which require to be
alongside the main routes
and they're not good neighbours to
residential developments
that people don't want noise because
these sites have to be
capable of working longer than the
normal working day
and therefore it makes more sense to
locate these away from residential
developments hence the point of
our pepperbot approach not necessarily
being uh
dementia with attracting the sort of
businesses that we would like
so there was a lot of discussion went on
there but the details are contained in
here
the principal thing is we're saying to
go back to the executive
to create or request the creation of a
further working party that does
extraordinary
responsibilities or or scope
to come back with the sort of things
you're quite rightly suggesting
um gordon um sarah you had your hand
raised
thank you um a really interesting report
and i think sometimes employment sites
get slightly left to one side
because housing predominates much of
what we talk about
but actually vital to the
the health wealth and well-being of team
bridge as a community
good quality um local employment is
going to improve
people's life chances and access to
housing and all those other things that
concern us most
so i think it's vital that this goes
forward to the executive
for broader discussion um a wider
strategic approach and a proactive
approach from the council so i'd be
willing to support that going forward
that's going thank you um
councillor swain
you're on mutant uh andy my apologies i
was so busy putting my hand down
uh thank you chair and thank you to
everyone that's worked on this report
um there seemed to be some some really
good ideas in here um
that are welcome and i do note the lead
officers comments about the costs and
resourcing of some of the ideas that are
put forward
um as we've seen from the recent budget
uh debate
um with the ongoing cuts in the central
funding there are tough decisions to be
made and the reality is
that uh putting forward a good idea
means another good idea somewhere has to
go by the wayside so
um i'm cautious that uh
these ideas are balanced um
and i'll give you a few more examples um
uh i represent a rural parish we've had
quite a few uh planning applications
come through recently for industrial
development
on a small scale which i think fits with
your your pepper pot model which you're
saying is a bad idea so i
agree there um but there have been some
very contentious
issues um there's been a rural building
which was disused that was um wants to
be converted to an industrial site and
the reality of that would have been
a a significant amount of hgb traffic to
a very remote rural location
um accessed next to a village which is
accessed by narrow lanes
it was very desperately unpopular with
the community um
and so for example conversion royal
buildings
uh isn't necessarily a policy that we
need to completely pursue
um they comment about approaching
landowners by roads
also something to add to that um yes
obviously there's benefit industrial
sites being by roads but possibly is
there a
an element of car based thinking here um
we we need to move to a less car
dependent society
i agree absolutely that we don't want
lots of small industrial sites
in amongst residential developers but we
also want
the employment sites to be not too far
from residential developers so
developments um so that walking and
cycling are realistic um
possibilities we need traffic-free
routes between
the residential and the commercial
developments
um so you know we need to broaden the
scope there slightly we need to be
looking for sites by main roads that are
not too far from residential areas as
well as not too close
and we need to look for traffic free
routes i think there's some important
things there
um yeah those are my points again thank
you very much for everyone involved
there's some good ideas and i do support
the proposal um
just pointing out that uh some of the
some of the specific recommendations
need to be balanced with other
requirements
thank you thank you i think the report
when he talks about rural communities
does make the point that there must be
appropriate developments and
i think appropriate encompasses all the
requirements to
address transport restriction you know
access
and things like that one of them
absolutely but it
i think uh the transport issues need
need to be said we need we need to talk
about car free routes and active travel
and
reducing car dependence thank you one of
the big concerns that came out
when we were talking to people was the
of the 1.5 million square feet of space
required a lot of that was coming from
current businesses that are within team
bridge
wanting to expand and grow and feeling
constrained that was stopping them
growing
the lack of space was forcing some of
these people to look beyond the realms
of team bridge
to create uh the sites where they could
develop and grow
since producing the report we've also
had the announcement that plymouth is
going to be a
freeport area that's going to put
additional pressure on potentially
businesses
high value businesses who operate in the
international market
seeking to take advantage of a freeport
then relocating to
or down to plymouth and one of the
concerns were that if we weren't
addressing and providing resources
within team bridge
we were actually promoting greater
levels of transport
because people would be therefore forced
to move away from team bridge
live in team bridge but then drive down
the a38 to
plymouth or potentially exeter so it is
a difficult
um conundrum it is a an issue that we
need to
live up to and recognize and and
consider how we address that
hence our comments that we need a
strategic
plan that covers employment as opposed
to just looking at employment sites
so it's it is a uh a complicated issue
that we need to get
the council needs to get its mind around
yes gordon
just to elaborate on two points and
first of all the the free court status
for
uh plymouth i've asked john hart the
leader of devon county council for
a report on the impact of of that new
status on devon and the economy of devon
because
you're right to point out as you do the
possibility of
it being a magnet and taking away from
but at the same breath
it might also be an opportunity that we
ought to be grasping i i know for
instance that the
the the solent uh freeport area
stretches from portsmouth through to the
new forest
a huge area and um it's just possible
that
certain parts of dublin i'm not saying
team is because i don't know
but it's possible that the there could
be positive impact
from that for us and i do think that we
ought to be exploring that as a
as a very real and immediate um
possibility
so that that's that point um
my second point is that on in 2.9
um going back to what we were talking
about previously
2.9 states that the demand for new
facilities is coming from manufacturing
warehousing distribution et cetera
where demand is strong i'm sure that's
right
so why aren't we building one or two
warehouses and
capitalizing on that demand we have
space for
what what's stopping us being proactive
and
supplying that need but it goes on to
say in 2.9
the requirements for offices is weak
well that that's an
absolutely entirely different message
than the one i'm getting from devon
county council where
they are about to announce i'm not sure
i should know
properly um the production of hubs for
uh sort of box and cox office use
um here in newt no but in timmouth now
you know the message therefore is is
contradictory
um and here is where you know where i'm
thinking that
it would have been advantageous to speak
to to devon council
devon county um direct we we seem to be
missing out on
on opportunities therefore i very much
welcome the report and
thank those who produced it and i very
much look forward to
the execs taking on this and maybe
giving
us you um the ability to progress
with other uh thinking on on more
entrepreneurial activity to generate
a a more sort of dynamic response here
in team bridge because
we seem to be missing out on
opportunities and i'm disappointed by
that
thank you i agree with your observations
um
so if i can just move on from there can
i ask
does um
well do i have any questions please from
nina nina jefferies
or anything you'd like to say nina
hello hello um thank you chair no i
don't have anything
to add i think the discussion has gone
really well today so i welcome
the report coming to exec and there's
been lots of discussion and advice in
hasn't there about kind of the things
that we could add to that
so i'll bear that in mind when it comes
and if anybody's got any points that
come up after the meeting if you can
just
maybe email me let me know um and i can
bring that to
exec alongside the report so thank you
everybody for the debate today it's been
good to listen to
thank you uh fergus page i can't see
your name on the
attendee list are you
i'm here oh do you have any comments
ferguson or any guy
you would like to have no i i don't
think so thanks for the
opportunity um governor next steps about
um
going to executive my comments are in in
the report and
um i think it's been a useful discussion
thank you
thank you in that case can i come back
to the uh committee please
um the proposal is this report is sent
as is to the executive for further
consideration
in line with the recommendations that
the report made can i have it through a
show of hands please that you approve of
that
so chair can we have a seconder for that
please
do i have a second left of the proposal
thank you sarah
can we show our hands again if you wish
it to go to executive
i think that's a unanimous nobody
against that sending it forward
no vote against no absolutely no
abstention
that's carried unanimously thank you
i have no further items on the agenda is
any
further questions that people would like
to ask
any issues you'd like to raise
in that case um
we're just short of our 90-minute
limitations so in that case gonna make
tallest meeting to an end
please and thank you all for your
attendance this morning
thank you